[Music]
i'm going to ask our panelists to
introduce themselves
with their name hometown and pre-gsb
location and then a fun fact of either
the best asian food in palo alto or
uh the thing that they have most enjoyed
making
like cooking uh if you cook no pressure
during cobin so with that mona i would
love to start with you
hi everyone it's great to be here today
um i
like jenna said i'm also an mba too
prior to the gsb i was in new york for
six years where i worked
in consulting with bain and then for the
city of new york
um my hometown it's a little bit tough
to always say
where i'm from but i've lived half in
china
in half in the midwest um and the u.s
and specifically
um in a number of different states
moving around every few years or so
um in terms of favorite asian food in
palo alto
um as a new yorker i would say that
uh the asian food in the bay area is a
little
less uh desirable than what i found in
terms of
kind of you know all the different
ethnicities that represent
asia however i would recommend
a new service called next dish um
essentially it's a service
that runs out of a cloud kitchen so
there's no
physical storefront um where there's a
lot of different home cooked
um asian items
that you can order for lunch or dinner
or even groceries
awesome thanks so much mona um kevin
over to you
all right um thanks jenna and uh it's
great to meet everyone here
um my name is kevin i'm a second year
mba as well
uh originally from a town called east
brunswick in new jersey
uh but most recently i
before the before school i was living in
seattle
uh working at a place called gates
ventures um
in terms of foods uh i've i've really
enjoyed cooking
different kind or trying out different
kinds of recipes
uh not always successfully uh
over the last few months but a couple my
favorites and these are pretty simple
um i actually just last night i made a
kind of childhood favorite dish um it's
a chinese dish called jajangmyeon
so it's this sort of like
it's like sort of salty uh sauce with
um pork and eggs and a bunch of veggies
with
chinese noodles and it's makes me feel
really nostalgic
and it's delicious um my fiance is
japanese and so we also make some
japanese foods another another favorite
of mine is oyakodon
which is just it's kind of just rice
eggs chicken and onions
and it's amazing that's so good kevin
uh we made jajangmyeon earlier this week
so feeling very connected to you
um and lorraine over to you
hey thanks jenna my name is naren i'm
originally from india i grew up in delhi
and i moved to the us for undergrad and
i've been in the bay area since then
um i was previously a pm at apple
on the iphone team so if you have any
iphone issues well you can
send those questions in the chat as well
if you want uh
um food
during covet i recently tried to make
[Music]
dosa which is a savory indian pancake
and i found a newfound respect for my
mom because
my daughter was nothing compared to what
she used to make at home so i just uh
called her in tears and i was like well
it's not tasty
give me all the tips but maybe i should
jump in and
kevin and jenna's uh cooking more often
now
[Laughter]
lauren i would love to learn how to make
this once you learn how to make dosa
from your mom
[Laughter]
well with that we can get into some of
these questions um that we've prepared
ahead of time
but also as we go if you have questions
for the panelists or if you have any
reflection
reflections or comments feel free to
submit them in the q a box
and we'll be collating them um both for
our q a session at the end as well as to
just to read out during the session um
so we'll spend about the next
20 minutes i think doing questions that
we've prepared and then
from there we will jump into open q a so
the first question i would love to start
with
and maybe naren pass this one to you is
can you tell me
just a bit about absa about the aven
business student association
and uh what kind of events or activities
does absa host
yeah for sure i mean absent has been one
of my favorite clubs to be part of at
the gsb
and even before sort of coming in right
from advent weekend uh
sort of engaging with the apsa members
um
they had like a small pop-up one hour
come meet up some members thing during
admit weekend
right since then i've been engaged um i
would i would sort of define apps as
sort of the
asian identity group uh at the gsb but
it's not
just related to identity so you can be
someone that identifies as asian and
obviously you're part of apps or can be
part of it but it's also for people that
are
interested in asian culture or asian
business in asia
and so we do sort of three kinds of
events one is sort of
the cultural related events so we have a
diwali event coming up this week
uh lunar new year uh events um
or or the other kinds of heritage months
for
uh the pacific islander heritage month
for example
and on the social front we have the
absolute retreat
that we try to host every year um
just a way to interact with the
classmates and get us a build a sense of
community across classes
uh we also have the apsa gala where we
invite leaders
uh like we had the ceo of dain and the
ceo of zoom
come in last year uh and sort of engage
with students there
and then also on the business front we
have uh like dabsagala we have other
events
to talk about what what is it what does
it mean to be asian in the workplace
and uh how do you sort of defy the
bamboo ceiling that exists and those
kinds of conversations as well so that's
the place
there's a place for that in apps as well
thanks doreen um what you were just
mentioning leads really into leads
really well into the next question that
i had which are
what are some recent topics that absa
has been engaging with and so maybe mona
and kevin would love to
bring you in here yeah i'm happy to take
that
um and i'll just add one more thing to
the
kind of traditional lust of events that
absent hosts
um this year is certainly a little bit
different than others however
in past years i think one of the
hallmark experiences for all of us
has been the retreat which every
identity group
has the opportunity to do so at the
beginning of the year i remember when we
were
mba ones we um went to a giant house
up in the hills somewhere in the bay
area overlooking the mountains
and we spent a day and a half talking
about identity
bonding over different types of asian
food that we were able to get
delivered to the area and it was a
really really nice
experience and this year we we
had to take that virtually but hope to
have you know
some smaller group events show the
conditions allow
but that's one of the things that's been
hallmark of identity groups
here at the gsb um back to your question
jenna of kind of
what are some of the recent topics we've
engaged with and
this year certainly i think with what's
going on in the
macroeconomic climate as well as
personal kind of desires
of this year's leadership we've really
tackled
try to tackle some of the harder topics
um and namely
um the couple that i'll talk about is
one we really try to get a better sense
of
what does being asian mean to you
um and you know a specific initiative
that we pushed out
is to really celebrate all the stories
we have about
asian identity during asian pacific
islander heritage month
and so you can check this out it's um go
to the urlapsastories.com
but really it's highlighting that asian
really means something different for
everyone
as someone that's grown up kind of both
in china
and the us for me being asian is
trying to reconcile these dual
identities together
jenna participated in these
kind of the reflection of these stories
and for her as a fourth generation
american with asian roots
that means a little bit different in
terms of how much she thinks about
cultural connections to asia versus you
know her true identity of
all the things that that make her more
um american
and and so that's kind of one the second
thing that
we are trying to have a little bit more
discussion around
is what is being an asian business
leader maine
and specifically reacting to some of the
data that
it is much harder for asians to progress
through the corporate ranks um and this
is kind of well researched
that asian and black females
are least likely once they've entered
into
the junior levels of the workplace are
least likely to progress to the sea
levels
and so we really want to get into some
of those topics um
and not only just position apsa as
a group where we come together socially
but but also to tackle these harder
topics
thanks amanda kevin what about you
yeah a couple other um topics of
discussion that have come up recently
that have been
kind of particularly relevant um mona
talked about this question of identity
uh the black lives matter movement and
protests over the summer have
really shown the spotlight on race in
america and also
led many of us to think about you know
what does it mean to be
asian to mona's point but also where
what what does
kind of asideness mean in this is very
u.s centric
than racial dialogue in america uh asian
is an
extremely heterogeneous group um with
you know it it's it's not uh that
where the the conversation is actually
pretty complex and we've tried to create
a space to have that both formally and
informally
um one last topic that i want to point
out is just
around civic engagement is tied back to
the others as well
obviously the the election is over at
this point but
um i think if if anything it's taught us
the importance of being civically
engaged
and we also want to create a forum for
discussing civic engagement um
among the asian community in the us and
how we can how we can contribute
yeah i find that a super interesting
topic kevin i know over the past few
weeks i've been reading a lot about
just like how hard it is to consider the
asian community in the us as a
homogeneous voting block
and so i imagine the conversations that
we're having in absa
um really helping to parse out some of
those differences
and i guess one way to take that
question forward is just thinking about
the gsb
community in general and kind of what
how would you describe
the gsb community um and how would you
describe sort of abs's place
within that community and and what that
has meant to your
sort of identity of being a student here
so
um i'll kind of leave it open or
lorraine or mona or kevin does that
question
sort of spark anything for you
i'm kind of thinking um it's a loaded
question
um i think i think one thing that
that um so i would describe the gsb
community as
it's kind of cliche to say this but it's
actually very diverse i mean
touchy-feely this quarter
and even people that uh
we think about diversity in terms of
race or
geography or something like that but
i've realized that beyond those things
the way
someone's statement what maybe one of my
statements lands on different people
even within the same race
is is just incredible how differently
people can perceive
different things and how the diversity
of thought there is really
uh something that stands out to me and i
think
that the gsb does a really good job of
you know
having diversity across all the metrics
that today quintessentially care about
like
race um or in different geographies like
40
student volleys international for
example but there's also a diversity of
thought and
for me personally the reason i'm part of
apps or i want to be part of this
discussion is i care a lot about
inclusivity
having been an international student
coming to the us
it's important to me to have to for
anybody that's new to the bay area or
new to stanford and new to the u.s it's
important for me to create a safe
community for them and
and so that they can be their fullest
self and they get to bring their
diversity of thought
once they feel safe and comfortable and
i think the gsb
and being part of apsa is really is my
way of contributing towards that
i love that and maybe just two quick
things um to help our
audience orient so touchy cle if you
don't know about it is a class it's one
of the hallmarks of the gsb experience
um it's formally called interpersonal
dynamics and so if you were to google
that you'll probably find some like
poets and quants articles about it
there's lots of stuff about it online
but it is very much focused on
um how does my experience uh differ from
the experience of those around me and
really
spending time in class discussing that
and really getting into some
some interesting and hard conversations
um
mona i think you are also going to say
something yeah i think i would just
add that even amongst the asian
community
here in the gsb there's a lot of despair
a diversity um kind of as
kevin mentioned it's not a homogeneous
group even though i think
close to a quarter if not more of our
students identify
as asian what we found is we have people
from east asia south asia central asia
south east asia
those who are asian american who are
second generation versus
many generations here versus ancient
international
internationals that have gone to college
here versus international
where this is the their first you know
longer term american experience
and also from different socioeconomic
backgrounds and
i think what we really try to do this
year is
bring all of that under the same
umbrella within
um apsa and actually try to get a little
bit more
foster a little bit more of those
subgroups of asia to kind of
get to know each other that may not
naturally come together
and something that we've done um trying
to be creative in the covert environment
is to create apps of families um and so
those are
little small groups of cross-class
cross-class groups where we are trying
to match based on the different
experiences
of how they identify with asia
one last thought i'd add is that um
we've talked about our
our backgrounds and uh people at the gsb
come from different places and
i've been actually pretty fortunate to
have um
grown up in a really diverse environment
and actually gone to
college also in a really diverse
environment um
one thing that i think is pretty unique
about the gsb though is the
um and noreen and jenna touched on this
a bit with touchy feely
there's just a lot of a lot more
discussion here um
about what that actually means uh and
and what that means to you personally so
these discussions about um identity and
diversity they happen
uh in a much more explicit and
vulnerable way
at the gsb than i've seen elsewhere and
so even if
you know i i've been lucky to have been
in diverse locations you know physically
but
um the the dialogue around that
and the emotional vulnerability here i
think is really unique
yeah i do think kevin that's such a good
point around
how we celebrate identities and how
those are maybe even brought into
class and experiences that differ from
just
sort of these extracurricular
opportunities something like abster the
diversity committee
i guess maybe building on that i would
be curious
for everyone's take on what role and
just diversity inclusion plays
in in spaces outside of just absolute
survey so in the classroom i think
marine you touched on this without you
feeling kevin you just mentioned this
are there other places where you've seen
this be um
something that the gsb does really well
or are there places where you're like
huh this is an opportunity
um or this is a place where i you know
this
sort of my identity really resonated um
in a space that wasn't necessarily like
an abscess space but more broadly in the
community
i can start with at least an opportunity
for improvement
um i do feel like while
the student body is diverse our faculty
and set of speakers have not reflected
the diversity that exists within the
student body i think there's a lot more
room
to think about diversity not just along
the gender lens
but also from all the different kind of
intersectional lenses that we just
mentioned
and i've seen some professors do really
good job with us
where i was just in a class it's called
entrepreneurial acquisition um but
the professor and the student
kind of teaching assistant spent the
entire
summer rewriting all of the cases used
in that class
um and i saw that even in an industry
um and this is talking about the search
fund industry where seven percent of
um searchers are female we saw
a wealth of backgrounds um gender
nationality socioeconomic background and
that was really really
really um encouraging to see and i would
like to see more of that in our
classrooms
yeah i'd say this is a kind of major
ongoing point of discussion of the gsb
in recent years there's one thing about
the gsb is
you kind of get grouped into various
formal and informal groupings
um as sort of like a way to get to know
your classmates and try different
situations and
just learn and talk about different
things but one of those
programs that has arisen in the last
couple years has been
this thing called pause you essentially
get grouped into
into groupings that are purposefully uh
diverse and representative and
the idea is to create a space where
people can talk about
um issues around identity and diversity
uh with people who are not necessarily
of a similar background to you
uh and for me that that's been a super
good experience
um but some of the things that mona
mentioned i think i resonate
on my end as well uh not all courses um
have done an equally good job uh of
making sure that there's representation
across
you know different um identities and
backgrounds
uh and sometimes you know you still get
situations where a lot of the guest
speakers in a class
end up being you know old white guys um
but
this is something that uh people
recognize
at the school and and are making a
pretty
conscious effort towards
yeah and i'll just add on quickly to
that i think uh what's funny is i think
all four of us are in this class
together called leadership perspectives
this quarter
where uh you bring uh leaders
in for a sort of an ask me anything kind
of situation
have them for about about an hour and
you get to ask them anything in a
non-recorded
setting and they just can completely be
open about their experience and
it's really interesting to uh ask them
about hey what was it like to be a
minority
uh person and rise up the ranks to be
ceo or how have you
uh you know managed family outside of
work and
just get these candid responses and to
kevin's point
uh the gsb is very open and you know
it creates a space for vulnerable
discussions to happen like this
and also to mona's point there's a lot
more to be done uh
in this direction
completely agreed uh yeah it is funny
that we're all in leadership
perspectives i think that's one of the
other classes
for anyone who's thinking about coming
right touchy feely leadership
perspectives
um there are some real highlights that
get passed down sort of year to year by
the mba too for the nba ones and so
as you go through our beautiful election
ranking process
i say that a little bit ironically it's
not a bunch of algorithms
um you get to you can decide what you'd
like to take and these classes are some
of the ones that are
always consistently picked first i
wanted to echo something that kevin had
said about pods and so
pods is a really interesting program
that is at the moment led by
students and by the diversity committee
which i'm part of
in helping right helping students
connect with one another
that was actually a pilot program that
was launched the year before
us um by students who thought you know
there's really not enough spaces to talk
about our different identities and to
sort of bring these to the forefront and
and help the informal groups that you
know form in any community
sort of extend beyond what's easy right
oh people who used to work in my
industry
or people who i live near people who are
from my hometown
and so paz was one way to kind of that
the diversity committee decided to make
this programming our own and i'd be
curious with absa you know certainly
there were things that the mba 2 is even
above
us put on so i'd love to hear maybe from
everyone
like a favorite experience that you had
of absa maybe during the mba one year
and then this year being in leadership
positions how you've made
absolutely your own and i think in some
ways mona maybe you've already touched
on this a little bit um
but sort of broadening the question to
everyone
um kevin if you have any thoughts you
should go i'm going to take a moment to
think
i feel like this is cold calling people
mona do you want to elaborate maybe
while kevin and lorraine take a moment
to think
um i actually i'll go back to my first
answer it was
the retreat and we're trying to
replicate that
those the sort of conversations that
took place um
through um our virtual retreat as well
as
um intentionally pairing people of
different backgrounds through our absent
families
um and really i do think it's those
conversations
realizing that oh i struggle with um i
you know being both chinese and
american and not knowing which part um
which country i have more allegiance to
or um i strug i struggle with
being insecure about you know how well
my chinese is like
realizing that others share the same
kind of
um perspectives i think that's really
what makes
app so powerful in my mind
yeah and i've even found those
conversations with yumona to be super
interesting right because i
equally struggle with my identity as
like a fourth generation american
chinese person
i don't speak any chinese and i was like
and when i know that you were taking a
bunch of chinese classes here at
stanford right
and like that stuff i feel like having
those conversations even in the first
place
um is a really just adds a lot of
richness to the experience here and a
lot of richness to the connections you
make
um kevin you had unmuted do you want to
jump in yeah i was
kind of struggling to think of like
something that wasn't the retreat
because that that was just awesome um it
was a lot of fun
and um also really meaningful um so i'd
say in terms of like then
maybe a thing that i don't know sticks
out about about my experience with absol
or kind of like
got me involved it it probably i would
have to say it
it's that um in terms of
i guess i don't know
shaping the club this year uh we're you
know in these unique circumstances where
um it's a lot more difficult to build
community uh given that we're all remote
you know a lot of a lot of or at times
hanging out looks like this
you know looks like uh a bunch of people
on a zoom screen
um which can be a lot of fun but uh
it's hard to replace you know having a
bunch of people in a big house
uh like talking about things face to
face with each other
making food together hanging out um
but i think one of the things that uh
mona mentioned earlier which i'm really
looking forward to we kind of just
started this
is this absa families thing so the idea
of having
you know groups of people get together
and i think the gsp is all
kind of about this you know it's a small
school to begin with uh
and having smaller you know various
kinds of groups that intersect in
different ways
and building more of these intimate
connections um
that where you kind of have the same
group of people um
across the the course of the year or or
beyond
having similar different kinds of
conversations where you can get a little
bit deeper
that's probably the thing that i i'm
looking forward to most
just to quickly jump on that um on top
of retreat which was
life-changing um i mentioned that
in advent weekend uh i had interacted
with some absolute members and that
that's what sort of got me involved with
this club and
uh what happened this was admin weekend
for me was in january and school was
starting in september
in the months leading up to that like
just unprompted
a few apps members started a facebook
messenger chat with me and a couple of
other
incoming students and these folks were
involved with apps
as current students and that sort of
became a
avenue for us to ask any questions to
them hey like what classes should we
take how many classes should we take
should we bring a car to campus like
random questions like that but
what that really showed is you know
these folks are going to look out for us
as mba ones
and out you know to create that kind of
environment cross-class bonding
would be one of the things we did over
the summer was uh
a matching between mba ones and nba twos
that maybe hadn't gotten to know each
other
uh within the absolute community so that
was an example of how to make
or how to foster that kind of community
this year especially given that it's all
been virtual
i lost my mute button for a second
thanks everyone i think something that
um
that makes me laugh so i didn't have a
chance to go to the absolute retreat
last year
um i have no doubt it was life-changing
um one thing i did want to highlight
that
happened last year that was really
impactful for me was the absa gala
and so i i think someone touched on this
a little bit earlier but
um basically it was this dinner event um
and
one of the highlights of the night was
this panel um with a bunch of different
people from really different backgrounds
so there was a woman who had been an
academic who turned into like a very
badass hedge fund manager
um she was really good at math there was
the ceo of zoom and there was the ceo of
bain
and i think one one area and the
conversation
did touch on the bamboo ceiling touched
on their experiences rising through the
ranks
um you know the guy at bain had a really
interesting perspective of what
what that was like in a very sort of
one of these big companies um where
diversity is traditionally maybe not
seen at the top
the ceo of zoom is really funny cracking
jokes all night
but i think even even moments like that
um
we talked about our experience and
leadership perspectives and how there
are a lot of
opportunities for classes here at the
gsb to do more
right just to better reflect the
diversity that exists out there in the
world and also in the student body
and i thought that the absolute um the
absa gala was one of the
places where i seen that reflected best
and just the power of bringing those
voices to campus
in a smaller setting to talk about these
kinds of issues around identity
was something that i hadn't seen done so
effectively before
so a big shout out i know that many of
you here were
helpers of organizing that event so i
guess belated thanks
these months on i'm going to transition
over to questions that we've gotten from
the audience
and so if you have any questions that
you would like me to ask
please feel free to submit them in the q
a box and we can start with a couple
um here and so one that we have
um is about how absa interacts with
other identity groups at the gsb
and what kind of allyship and coalition
building might look like
for a brief preview as mona and naren
and kevin
you start to think there are many
identity groups here at the gsb
i would say eight or nine at last count
right so
absa um there's the bbsa the black
business student association
the native business student association
hispanic business student association
you kind of get the gist and so really
curious yeah what that kind of
interaction looks like
um and can turn it to our panelists uh
to hear their thoughts
uh yeah i can i can take this they're um
they're sort of formal and informal
channels of interaction
um formal channels jenna maybe you can
actually talk a little bit more about
how the
diversity committee kind of encourages
and and enables it
um so there's so there's that uh
recently there's been
um i guess you know in light of current
events there's been
uh an allies for black lives movement
and organization that has popped up on
on campus that has enabled some more of
this dialogue but
i'd say like the default actually is a
lot of this interaction happens
more informally um so it's
i mentioned that the class is relatively
small and so we have friends who are
part or members of or leading these
different identity groups
and so a lot of coordination or um just
dialogue generally happens
through these informal channels
but jenna maybe you can talk a bit more
about formally
yeah it's a really good question so the
mission of the diversity committee
is to support students and liaise with
the gsb administration
in making sure that the gsb is a diverse
and inclusive and place that
that fosters belonging i think kevin
exactly to your point a lot of this
coordination takes place informally
and sort of relies on networks that are
you know established from knowing each
other in class or
having been roommates or whatnot and so
one thing that we're really focused on
is trying to formalize those connections
one thing that we do currently is
provide a quarterly space for
kind of best practices ideas sharing
even just like
hey what's what's hard right like what
are you doing about retreats this year
um four identity groups to come together
and start talking about that
um i also know that the diversity
committee there will be times when
for example a lot of the events that
happened over the summer right it's how
do we
best support um say like the black
business student association
um and i think one opportunity for us is
thinking about allyship in those ways of
not just reaching out to the black
business student association
you know when when stuff goes down but
really how do we come together as a
community
to support um more effectively
and really like just yeah show how much
we care about one another
so thank you for those questions um one
that came in um also is about
could you talk about the impact your
asian identities had on your pre-mba
work experiences
and how your perspectives have changed
if at all during your time at gsb
one thing i can say as i um as i just
think through this question a little bit
more i think this is a
really interesting one is that um
to be honest i i wasn't as thoughtful
about
the impact of my asian identity on my
work experiences
prior to business school i had
worked in consulting
and then went to work in global health
and
um in a lot of cases i was working on
working with small teams uh or
when i was working global health kind of
like internationally um
but to be honest mostly i just hadn't
been quite as thoughtful
about it as i probably should have been
and coming to the gsb has
almost like in a way just removed a
blind spot
for me to to really think about this
question some more so
for me i think this is still you know
work in progress um
thinking reflecting on on how my
experience was in the past and how i'll
take
my i guess better understanding of i
i've identity forward
i can i can try to kind of provide my
perspective on that um
i feel like i've always keenly been
aware
of um the specific challenges of
being asian in the
business world um i was involved
with our asian american student group
when i was in college and actually
started um grassroots effort to launch
an asian identity group um at the
consulting firm that i worked with
um but i think one of the things coming
here
it's given and having conversations
hearing other students say
hey i feel like asians
aren't being supportive of each other
enough um in the
workplace on seeing some of the data um
and research around the bamboo ceiling i
feel even more
emboldened um to be vocal
about hey there are some specific issues
that pertain to asians that we need to
really highlight
and and that i can help um
i can personally contribute um in
places that i go in the future um so i
feel really
good about just the amount of reflection
that's taken place
um to
give me um even more confidence that
this isn't
there are issues to tackle
actually one other thing i'd say is that
um i think
one thing that i've thought about more
is the the importance of
um having good role models and being a
good role model
uh we talked earlier about um how
awesome it was to have
this panel at the gala where
we had you know role models of really
successful
um asians who had uh
yeah just in many ways kind of crushed
it at whatever it was that they were
doing
in fact i was pretty fortunate in that i
sort of had that
when i was at gates ventures that the
head of my team was from india
when i was before that i worked at the
clinton health access initiative
and the evp who was in charge of my
teams from malaysia
and i sort of i took that for granted a
little bit
and it's just the experience here has
made me think about how fortunate i was
in that context and how you know in the
future
that's something that i'll continue to
seek out and something that i'd like to
i'd like to be you know a good a good
role model in the future
yeah that definitely resonates with me
um
of i think kevin how you how you
described it of removing a blind spot
um i think is true to my own experience
um lorraine did you want to jump in or i
can move to a
new question as well yeah i mean i think
for me
it's uh before gsb it was uh
i was sort of very involved with the
indian community in undergrad for
example
and uh when i went to apple i realized
that you know companies have
traveled a lot to asia and that's when
sort of i i'm my
not blind spot but i guess my vision
sort of opened up to
being like hey there's a lot of
commonalities here about the
conversations that i've been having with
my
indian community that can be drawing
parallels with the rest of the asian
community and so it's sort of slowly
broadening the gsb is getting a little
broader
uh there as well but uh yeah i think
it's it's it's super important and i
think and now
creating and that's what we're trying to
do is trying to create more avenues for
these conversations to become
commonplace
and that's sort of one of the objectives
for us
thanks so much um one question just as
we're talking about sort of our
professional experiences and how they've
changed the gsb
um someone had asked how absa and maybe
how we each individually leverage the
alumni network
to expand the range of career
opportunities as we're thinking of
moving forward and so i think this
question is particularly about career
opportunities and working in asia
but would be curious um you know i know
noreen you mentioned this texting group
of mba twos or those kind of showing you
the way
what does it look like to to be an ab
site even after uh gsb and are there
people that you're leveraging as you
think about career choices moving
forward
yeah i'll take a stab at that um
a couple of ways that that app says
involved from a career perspective one
is
last year um the the leadership team had
organized a bunch of uh
dinners or brown bag lunches with
alums who from the asian community from
the gsb who are willing to sit down with
a small group of like seven or eight gs
beers and
just uh provide advice and so we we got
to do that with
startup founders we got to do that with
some some folks in the vc community as
well and sort of
knowing and they were always like hey
here's my email
which reach out to me whenever you want
like let me help you
in your career and help you get give you
perspective about anything so that's one
the other thing is we uh
we're sort of tied with the the career
management center here whenever there's
a job posting that's sort of related to
asia
or that they want us to sort of blast to
the rest of the asian community here we
sort of our channel
towards that so those are the two ways
we're engaged
i can add on to that a little bit
i think uh noreen mentioned a little bit
about the role
of the career management center they're
certainly essential
in you know being the funnel for
opportunities that come from
um companies that are really looking to
hire in asia
however we also have pretty active
career groups
career clubs at the gsb and i think some
of them have done a really good job with
highlighting
you know different experiences
internationally so for example this year
the venture capital club has done a
really great job of
hosting separate panels of those that
have worked in vc
um for for example like um eastern
europe and
in north africa and certainly there will
be an asia panel
um and in addition to the small group
dinners that naren mentioned
um we are really trying to
find ways to highlight role models um
in in this space and the apps of gala is
certainly one way
of doing that um but we're also trying
to
foster more conversations um just as how
we're fostering conversations
between the students we're trying to get
a little bit more dialogue
between students and alumni in the space
and so tonight actually
there is an event that the club is
hosting with um
the the folks that have started um the
asian affinity group at mckinsey
and they're hosting a fireside chat um
for anyone interested in consulting but
also
wanting to talk about what it means to
be asian and consulting
and just to get a little bit more
dialogue
in through that way um so those are the
student alumni connections
and i would say the asian alumni group
here the gsb
is super active um there's a lot of
alumni to alumni connections and they
host events that we
that are open to students um but they i
know that they also have
mentor groups um with amongst themselves
and get together
pretty regularly
that's exciting um i guess kevin did you
want to jump in or
um there are a lot of questions that i'm
happy to move to
yeah let's make sure let's try to get in
more some more questions
awesome yeah so the next one is really
about how you balance all of this
and so um one of the questions is all
the activities and discussions that
absolutely sound really interesting
how do you manage to balance this
someone else asks how did you
or why did you choose to become involved
in absent broadly how do you allocate
your time among the various
activities and that you're pursuing here
at gsb
time management i'm gonna take notes if
anyone has great solutions
because i certainly haven't figured it
out um panelists what do you think
yeah maybe i i can uh jump in and say
that i don't do this well
so i guess the how i manage my time
across different things
um poorly for the most part
uh yeah i mean i this is a this is a
thing that i think
um a lot of us at the gsb talk about
and i don't know like complain in a good
natured way about just that there's so
much
stuff going on there's so much to do
there's so many things that you want to
be involved with
that it's very common for people to
over commit themselves to a bunch of
different things classes take some time
uh there are lots of interesting
speakers that various groups will bring
in
um
there are a ton of extracurricular
activities that you can be a part of
some people work on the side
do some independent research and all
this at the same time we're
trying to find internships and jobs um
so i don't know i don't have a really
good answer to how you actually go about
managing your
time other than that you literally have
to and so in that way it kind of
you're because your time is finite
you're sort of forced
to almost like force rank the things
that you do and
um and that that's the way so just
necessity maybe it's one way
i don't know motor and rain if you guys
have good tips and tricks here
i feel like we're all laughing at that
question but i think i
i want to come back to a really a piece
of really valuable advice i received
before coming to business school
which is know exactly what you want to
get out of the next two years it's gonna
fly by and that's certainly
true and i would add know what you're
willing to trade off
um and i think myself in particular
um some of the trade-offs i make because
i feel like it gives me more time to
devote to things extracurriculars like
afsa um jenna and i i've also started
another club
focused on the future of cities and but
for example some of the trade-offs i
make are i
devote less to classwork i sometimes am
always that person
not having uh done the readings in a
cold call class
um but for me the ability to
take a step back on academics in order
to give me time to focus on the clubs
that i really care about
to you know work part-time and and do
independent research
that's worthwhile and so you just have
to know
what is most valuable to you
something that's been interesting for me
thinking about the gsb
um is also who you choose to do
who you choose to do these activities
with and so
one perspective i have um of apps is
that the leadership team
of which i'm not a part is actually
quite close
right and i think that there's a lot of
value in
when you think about balancing your time
between different activities it's kind
of like who
who are you in that boat with i know
that the diversity committee i
spent a lot of time on that one because
it's meaningful to me but two because
it's
people that i care about deeply right
and we're trying to make a difference
and trying to give back to the gsb
community and so um
i think one way that i have often
thought about cutting like how i spend
my time
is kind of like which relationships
content too but which relationships am i
investing in
um and and how do i see that playing out
okay i'm going to move to a question
actually about so we've talked a lot
about the gsb and sort of what is app
how is it sort of shaped and informed
your own experience here
um there are a couple of questions about
how absa relates to other stakeholders
across stanford and so whether it's
faculty at the gsb
um someone had asked about
undergraduates at stanford right so
there's
an asian community of undergraduates at
stanford you know broadly the university
and then also um the local bay area
right now like asian people in the bay
area
so curious for kind of what those
interactions look like or what they
might look like
um if that's even part of the scope of
apsa
uh yeah so so um
first of all i i'll broadly say i think
one
so so we the short answer is apps it
generally does do this
but one thing i'd broadly say is i think
one i'm one criticism i have of the gsb
overall is that it can be a little bit
insular as a community it's an
incredible community
within the gsp but um i think
in some ways there's sort of a missed
opportunity when it comes to
connecting with the rest of stanford and
maybe beyond in some ways
um but yeah so so we
do try to reach out to uh other asian
groups
within stanford um in particular
and so i'm trying to think what was the
this is about asian groups in stanford
faculty
and then also the broader community
sorry i know it was a lot of groups
um so we have contacts with other asian
grad students or grad groups across
stanford
this year we haven't had events with
them but in the past we actually have
done these kinds of like
cross-grad student group mixers
it's been a little bit tougher this year
given the pandemic situation
but it's something that apps has done in
the past when it comes to
professors this is something that we do
we do have
we we work with professors on a somewhat
informal basis so when it comes to civic
engagement for example
we're working with a professor named
neil malhotra who teaches ethics
and is is kind of an awesome guy also
um i don't know a bay area more broadly
i'm trying to think if we
do this kind of beyond the way that we
engage with alumni but motor and rain if
you guys
have perspectives on this please jump in
one thing that i noticed even was
something as small as like i think about
diversity inclusion and corporate
setting is often supplier diversity
and so i know for a recent event
although we can't meet in person mona
had source
or possibly someone else on the
leadership team had sourced um this new
ramen startup
that was operating out of the bay area
and so i think even if there aren't
formal connections with
let's say like you know the asians of
the bay area
um there are ways that i think uh the
group is
is staying in touch um kind of locally
um so whether that's startups
as you mentioned the local alumni
chapters or even something small like
where do we get our food for an event um
and looking to support the kind of like
local asian purveyors yeah that was
mona's brainchild it was a huge hit
in the gsb maybe that should have been
my favorite food during kovid
[Laughter]
ramen hero for anyone that's interested
um
okay i'm gonna close with one final
question from the audience before
wrapping up with a lightning round um so
this is from uh from stephanie what were
your transformational aha moments
in your personal or leadership
development that you've experienced at
the gsb
that have made you feel confident in
your past to becoming an asian leader
so maybe you had an aha moment in a
class
when traveling in an internship but what
has sort of
been a transformational moment if you
think about moving forward to becoming
an asian leader
um i've been going first a lot so but
i'm conscious of that
but i have just a quick thought on this
uh
in asian culture or in indian culture
that i've experienced
where we're often taught to be silent or
not share
our viewpoint uh just in the moment
and uh what the gsb really pushes you to
do is
uh through these classes about
vulnerability or like interpersonal
dynamics that i mentioned
really let those feelings sort of bubble
up or thoughts
and then be able to share them in a way
that you're on your side of the net and
you're not really attacking
someone else if you have difficult
conversations to have or to give
feedback and
so what i've really come out the aha
moment here is that i have a framework
to now have difficult conversations
with people in the workplace and i
wouldn't have been able to get that out
if i didn't come to the gsb
next um i feel like i've
had two moments that get at the same
theme
um and really it's coming out
of i feel like there is
a model of what people expect
an asian female to act in in the
workplace
and i'm really not that um i think
there's a part of me that is can be very
vocal and direct
and that may come as a surprise to
people who have not interacted with me
um more closely in a work setting um so
i've always
held back on my opinions
and thoughts in groups that i may be
unfamiliar with and there
these two events the first is
um in nba one year we have something
called
uh lead labs um and so it's small
groups of folks that get together role
play different situations that
are you know tricky um
and i remember all of my squad mates
giving
me feedback saying look we really value
your perspective please
speak up more and i actually feel like
you you're holding back
um and a similar situation where
at the beginning of this year nba two
year
we had a new series called first
lectures
um and so that was bringing in the
highlights of all the you know best
classes
at the gsb and having those professors
do a day-long course that's a condensed
version of their quarter
long course um and and there was a class
called paths
to power which is you know the
anticipate of
what touchy feely teaches um it's a it's
a little bit different of a
thesis um and but
it it's not really the messages in those
classes
that really helped me realize this it's
the small group
interactions that i had with my breakout
groups of
you know another classmate saying like
hey like
please like share your perspective i
feel like you're holding back
um and so those those sorts of
opportunities for feedback have really
helped me
understand where i could
be more confident versus where you know
i actually
truly should be holding back
for me it wasn't so much i don't know
like a single transformational moment
but um you know we were talking about
how people uh just talk about their
feelings a lot here
um and and literally like articulate
them
put attach words to maybe concepts that
might otherwise feel kind of fuzzy
and um one thing i thought as i
have just you know discussed the topic
of asian identity
more over time is that i'm actually i'm
really proud of my
identity it's something that i sort of
always felt a little bit in the
background but
to actually attach a word to it it's not
like i learned the word proud when i was
in the gsb you know but like to actually
attach the word to the feeling um has
felt
really empowering uh so that's one thing
that that's
i don't know it's like it's almost given
me a uh
like a like an explicit confidence um
over my time here and then the other
thing is going back to this point around
um having good role models and being
good a good role model
having the sense this feeling of
responsibility that i want to be a good
role model
in the future um so
i guess those couple things make me
both give me the confidence and
kind of this feeling of duty as i go
forward in my career
i love all of those takeaways um
before we do our lightning round i'm
going to
give the panelists a sense of what i'll
be asking so basically
what advice would you give to yourself
right as you were applying or before
serving the gsb
um and while you think about that um i
will uh just take a moment to thank
everyone for being here today
um this has been a lot of fun thank you
all so much for your questions and
putting them into the q a box
i hope that this has been insightful and
it's given you a sense of what it's like
um to participate in absa or to be a
student here
and also i know that will is here from
the mba admissions office and so if you
have any questions that we didn't answer
um we'll find a way or maybe he'll come
on at the end and say how to get your
questions answered
so with that having given you a few
moments to think
uh we'll do the lightning round so kevin
we'll start with you what advice
would you give yourself uh before coming
to the gsp
whether applying or before starting yeah
the biggest piece of advice i would give
myself
is just to make time to settle down and
think
before school i i totally did not do
this and that's why
it's so salient um basically like
my sequence was i i worked right up
until school started
uh when on this um a vacation that was
not really it was it was not a chill
vacation
uh with my fiancee we went to china and
japan
came back two days later started school
joined the slack channel
for the first time at that point uh and
still worked part time
during my first couple quarters of the
gsb and as a result
i didn't really get a chance to sit down
and clear my mind and think about things
um until like the two one or two weeks
before
the winter quarter started uh and i wish
i'd done that beforehand i wish i'd
taken
like a month off at least uh to
to disconnect a bit from what i had done
before
and really be as deliberate as possible
about
what i wanted to do at school even get
some research done ahead of time
like i had goals and ideas but
i felt unsettled when i um when i first
started and actually that feeling lasted
quite a while so i said that so
giving yourself some some space and time
before school
is what i recommend thanks kevin uh
moda over to you i would say
be more proactive in meeting others and
and i think that comes in two ways one
is
once you get admitted there's this
amazing network
of admits that you can tap into and i
remember being in new york there were
so many informal meetups meanwhile i
you know i i felt like i need to
prioritize
my current set of friends making sure i
maximize the amount of time
i have with them and i'm trying to you
know finish up work
um before i leave because i feel like um
there's
we need to hit another milestone um but
i wish i had taken some more time into
getting to know
uh people prior to coming to the gsb
but also once i was at the gsb and i
think this sense of
feeling unsettled is not unique um
even if you've taken time off like i did
over the summer
there's a lot to disorient yourself in
the first quarter you're trying to
figure out how much do i really need to
spend on classes
this is what are all the all the social
events i should actually attend
um but i wish it was more proactive in
setting up one-on-one chats with people
because that's what i've
that's what i found most valuable um
here so far
just understanding where people are
coming from
what their interests are and including
getting together with people with shared
interests
all the time i love that and the rain
last but not least yeah real quick uh
one thing i would suggest is take some
time to think about what
you think or what you can bring to the
gsb community it means two or three
things uh as a student or as a member of
the community it's a very small
community so there's
if you know once you're admitted uh
there's gonna be very few people that
are like you so you're bringing
something that's unique
uh and uh that'll help you in crafting
your application
that will also help you prioritize uh
what you want to focus on
while you're a student and it'll also
give you a perspective of what you want
to learn
from the gsb thing blind spots are
things that you want to take as well
wow panelists thank you so much uh
we'll do a virtual and somewhat
imaginary round of applause uh because i
don't think we can hear from any of the
attendees
but thank you again for being here um
this is incredible